this seems so like dead spaces shoot
their limbs this is so that hello
everybody my name is Markiplier and
welcome back to Callisto protocol you
didn't hear it because it was right
before I started recording but there was
a big loud noise and it spooked me
wait but
but I saved after going through the
didn't I
did I not
did I did I not did I did I not uh
whatever fine I'll do this again I'll be
right back
hey gang welcome back to Callisto
protocol you definitely didn't see
anything before this and if you did you
definitely didn't so don't tell anybody
anything about what you did or did not
do or she because it's not important to
the story right now in fact it just
doesn't matter so let's not talk about
it at all and let's get back into
Callisto protocol
hello
okay so this goes back to where I were
that's good I'd hate to have to
backtrack it all that would be super
unfortunate also I don't even remember
why I'm
no no oh no no
no no no no no
thankfully those babies had money on
them
all right did I do it or did I do it I
don't know if I did it did I lose it
I might have dozed it
one for good measure I know I'm Wasting
Bullets but I'm really not a bullet
specialized kind of guy I'm all about
the melee
do I gotta go back now is am I done uh
I'm guessing I'm done
with whatever the hell I was supposed to
oh over there I saw that through the
window that was an environmental clue
that they gave to me I'm sure that's
fine I'm sure that's something I don't
need to worry about I'm sure that's
totally okay
and more [__] great
that's what I was open for
wow shimmy and a [__] that is wonderful
okay
who's moaning
why is every disaster horror game ever
have everyone just moaning in the
distance
you'd think that there would be so much
less moaning in a horror situation but
there's just so much moaning
look at that it's cacophony of orgies
happening off in the distance great good
more poop
hello no try me
yeah I'm getting good at that I am using
too many bullets I don't even
technically need to use my bullets for
those combos I mean I should say whoa
what am I hearing whoa whoa something
else is in here
I heard two things
hey what's up bud oh you don't like the
light oh no
just happened did you
did you melt him
how'd you melt him no that's a block
okay so I can block that that's good
try to block this douche
oh no
thank you
oh nice yeah there's got to be some like
environmental interaction things with
that but I haven't really gotten it you
know through his science just yet and I
think when he shot that other guy he
just atomized into a pile of Limbs I
don't know how that happened but he
literally disassembled him with a single
one of those so thank goodness that
didn't hit me as that would have been
bad for my health and general
disposition I can't see anything
you're not
you're not you're not I'm not what
didn't get to finish the message
people even in the throes of a demonic
Invasion still gotta do some graffiti
every once in a while
hello what are you
probably not important jerk
do do you do you see what's going on I
don't see what's going on tell me some
of your thoughts me why don't you talk
to me me never talk to me anymore but me
don't know what I'm doing
that almost scared me oh
[Music]
get out of here what are you doing oh I
thought I was
oh yeah
I'm here you stop oh okay that's a
little rude
there
man I still didn't get too much damage
out of that just shows I'm getting
better or something I really am liking
the game like I I know I came into this
a little sarcastic and a little bit like
displeased with things and you know the
direction of thing but now that I'm
actually into it and you get past like
the first opening sequence and all the
tutorials and whatnot
what is happening
oh
okay three of you eh how about take one
of these oh your friends are uh Gone
what do you think of that pretty weird
huh
whoa hey what the hell was that
not sure what that was about but a 106
credits I'll take it
ah hello
there we go plenty of bullets that's why
I'm not worried about Wasting Bullets
they do give you a ton now what I want
to know is when I'm going to get a new
inventory slot or something like that
okay but I got that did I get everything
in there I kind of got distracted by
everything going
so I wasn't able to actually remember if
I did what I needed to do I did not wow
I almost left all that
inventory full well damn it well nothing
I could do about that
all right that's just got to stay I
haven't been using my grip except for
when I exploded them with an explosive
Barrel so I guess I'm entirely wrong
with what I'm saying I actually have
been using my grip and very effectively
to be honest but my general disposition
is that I'm always wrong
am I getting surrounded I feel like I'm
getting surrounded am I getting
surrounded why do I hear some I swear I
feel like there's oh you're a clown Oh I
thought it was a clown hey okay that's a
little weird what are you doing were you
were you doing a little like oh I'm so
coy oh no it's just innocent little me
there you go that low block oh my God
what let's shut this down all this uh
spitting nonsense
oh
Norms oh your arms is blown man those
give a lot of credits
I take more of those I mean they hit
hard but you know not that bad
I ain't no baby for 100 credits of Pop
I'm gonna take him
I'll take them on
like it's just like this game is is
really growing on me so fast they
patched out the performance things which
I knew would happen like it's hard to
judge a game even a triple a game to
being like Oh there's performance issues
like out of the gate it's clearly
pushing Hardware in this one so that's
understandable I've played some ass
performing uh Indie Games before that
even on the Top End Hardware don't run
well so it can happen
um and as soon as it got patched out man
this game is it's really fun it's
beautiful it's gritty I like the combat
again I know it's divisive but the more
I do it the more I like it
there what is uh hold on
number six zeldon there's there's
something over here maybe there might be
something over here
see see you see
good thing this still works somehow
what all right
oh
what
what what
I didn't see it do it again
what
you have something to say about that
buddy
what do you think is going on here huh
do you have a little Elixir looking over
your shoulder as well
I hope so
[Laughter]
don't worry guy you don't have you don't
have a little Legacy and looking over
your shoulder don't be paranoid come on
now
wait am I going should I not have gone I
feel like I shouldn't have gone this way
I was I was thinking this was like a
side path and not necessarily
I mean it still might be a side path I
guess
storage Hall storage hall there's no way
this has got to be a side path and just
because I'm spooked about it
that is wrong way to go
hello
who's in there
[Music]
where am I
I'm gonna keep going forward but I'm I'm
not sure what I'm if I was supposed to
be doing
I'm a little confused
oh
what are we doing here
oh what what what what what what who
what what what what what what
what's happening I don't know what's
happening I don't know where I am I
don't know what I'm doing
hello
oh babies
let me hear you
am I on the open
[Music]
come here where I can blast you
I'm sorry I meant hug
yeah what was going on here I don't know
I don't even want to know
I don't know fascinating
oh hi uh
you okay buddy what was I supposed to
come here I don't have any idea
evacuation
contact mower
they'll save us
uh-huh okay good lovely uh consequences
of hidden research facilities doing God
knows what
that's weird
I don't like you I don't like you none
of this oh my God
oh my God
okay so this isn't this was a side thing
this was a side thing
I can't carry any of this I could shoot
four bullets bang bang and that would
free up some space yep oh I gotta clear
him out definitely gotta clear him out
can't have any Whoa by your tootsies no
way ain't gonna let that stand just like
you're never gonna stand again
that cleared that out and I guess it's a
pristine energy converter because that's
money right there that's Moolah and then
I can come back for this if I get so
Uchi that I need to get more Uchi
medicine
get more ooch juice inject it into my
neck
don't know why I came here but I
certainly did
hopefully nothing will jump out of me
now that I've gotten out of there
backtracking through a place I thought
was safe is definitely a way for me to
let my guard down
what happened to this guy
well he'll probably be fine
well
is someone there
oh my God it's a clown
hello
get out of here
oh nice noise what do you think of that
buddy huh oh you got your arms let's fix
that
ah well you're dead I thought we were
gonna play a little more I don't like
that one I don't like that one
I don't like you or there's got to be a
shop somewhere around here
since that definitely was a side path
I'm guessing I did good I feel good I
feel good about what I did I feel great
about what I did actually I feel
fantastic
so glad
really dark in here huh
really moody and dark
this might actually be one of the first
Unreal Engine 5 games that I played I
think this is unreal five it looks like
unreal five just because it looks great
looks fantastic actually
that's gotta imagine
full up on bullets
lots of bullets
but they leave bullocks
[Music]
yes sir just wrapping up
get the code from the guard well good
thing in the recording he'll be exactly
where his voice came from
this I know
hello
here's a lot of steam
oh whoa
oh whoa hello
hello who's here
who's back there
ooze but I'm not collecting a damn thing
till I know I'm alone I don't like that
well that can wait I don't know what the
hell I just saw but oh okay
online
all right can I sell this I got
delicious delectable whatever these are
also how do I upgrade my uh inventory
I get full up all the time
health is full well I don't need health
wow
your JC printing At Your Service yeah I
can sell these health
so goddamn amazing at this that I don't
need them
oh my health is full that's not a health
injector that's a health
thing bonus whatever you call it I don't
even know what it is
bullets credits
bullets and I think I have enough money
to upgrade ujc printing for all your
needs
I mean the damage does the damage right
am I crazy the damage the damage seems
like what it should be
finished thank you
thank you very much
velocity why not
screw it why not I throw things harder I
make my muscles bigger
cool thanks all right that's good enough
for me God damn it's dark
oh do I really have to can I shoot that
I'm going to shoot me into it I'm brave
I'm brave whatever the hell that is in
my way I'm brave
I'm brave I'm brave look at how Brave I
am
oh oh no hey well
all right took care of that nonsense why
am I stuck all right
take care of
that shoot the tentacles ah that seems
so familiar
this seems so like dead spaces shoot
their limbs this is so that
it's a thingy ow oh
exposed tentacles will cause enemies to
mutate
oh my God
holy [__] don't whoa
well it didn't seem any tougher so I'll
take him
oh
exposed tentacles are a warning that the
enemy is about to mutate into a stronger
form mutated enemies have more health
and stronger attacks shoot the exposed
tentacles to quickly kill the enemy
stomp on down to enemies from prevent
them from mutating further and attacking
again
okay good so I gotta look out for that
all right I'll keep my peepers peeled
thanks buddy
you mind if I stab your neck a bit
I don't exactly know how I
integrate this into myself
do I just slap it on top of mine
because I just seem to put it in my
pocket and then suddenly I'm able to do
everything
well let's listen to a story
oh that's good
otherwise
oh wait no no no no no no no no no no
[Music]
well good thing they didn't do that
until just this moment
[Applause]
okay
well thanks for giving the advice I
guess
who's there
who's there someone with tentacles I'm
on the lookout
well I don't see any you seem normal oh
all right
I feel like I should be able to hit them
if they're I feel like I should be able
to okay
what are you doing what are you guys
doing what are you doing you okay you
guys all right you okay buddy you okay
hello
foreign
okay
oh come on
don't do it oh God damn it
did it no he's gonna mutate
somehow I won that I don't know how
Oh no you're gonna well all right hold
on
huh
all right
that worked that was very messy I don't
know why that was so sloppy I've never
performed as poorly as Ed in my life
I should use my grip
you don't need to stomp in frustration
there pal it's gonna be okay
this we all make mistakes sometimes you
just gotta let it go
try again next time be a little better
learn from your mistakes it's okay
I don't like the grumbling
what was that grumbling that I heard
immediately over to my left
cycle
where is it gonna Purge it to
that's it's not water I know it's not
perfect cycle in progress
oh
warning anomaly detected oh good you had
detected an anomaly
interesting
oh
okay
where are you going
where you going buddy
interesting it turned invisible
somehow
well that wasn't so bad
who's there
where was it oh it was up I missed well
that was a waste
oh God no oh wow how did I do that
didn't know I could Dodge you I see you
there
are you dead good good thing you guys
are so easy and I have so many bullets
is there another one of those explodies
please tell me there's another one of
those explodies oh please tell me that's
not the sound of it creeping up on me
hey hey
oh God all right they're not so bad
where are you going you little scaredy
baby
oh you're dead
well this is bad at all I think that
might be
my air tank or something something over
here
how uh done are you done you done good
open
this is a good thing
activate ladder control wow okay
you couldn't do that on your own you had
to get me to do that
kind of pathetically
kind of extraordinarily pathetic of you
I don't have a map or anything do I
there's no map
wait but is that a health thing I need
that
how much health do I have I could I
could well let me let me see what's in
there first have I been here let's just
loop back this just Loops back I'm gonna
use it
I mean if I stab myself in my neck I
would say a lot more than gay ah
price
why is this the technology of the future
I'd be shouting a lot of these things
nonetheless I'm gonna climb into a poop
tank instead
oh God I really am going to climb into a
poop tank oh God I'm well oh that's fine
bet you were wish you were in here
in the poop tank
you're getting pressure tank pressure
check
you waving at me oh hand gone
right fine damn thing won't quit
no would you
would you
God is there even air in here yeah no
kidding it's been stinking forever it's
only been stink this entire is there
gonna be a river of poo am I gonna get
chased down by a river of poo
like in that Resident Evil or the
crocodile in the sewer uh
money
that's weird noises
anyway I'm not going to think about that
too much
I guess
[Music]
I am
I don't like
I don't like this why are there
orchestras hiding in the sewers
oh
yeah uh maybe maybe movement may I knew
River poop
yeah River boot okay
yo oh I'm doing this
oh God obstacles
oh boy man this is gonna be burned into
my memory well oh my God
oh my God holy crap
okay I gotta actually Focus here oh
that's uh whoa okay all right you
tricked me on that one you gave me a
little bit of the spooky
all right good
ow
God damn where is this going to
oh wait a minute well oh my God
no now purple get in my wounds
well I went the wrong way I should have
known it was it was quite obvious but uh
here I'll do that again okay it really
seemed like
you know they say when you do exercise
you want to do both sides so you
build muscle and strength uniformly so I
just wanted to do the other side all
right I see my Gap
I see my Gap
oh I don't see my Gap I see my Gap oh
God I saw my Gap huh how am I supposed I
can't even see
oh oh owie that's fine that's fine
fine
that's fine
he's dork
[Music]
am I done
oh
[Music]
you don't know about my e skills you
weirdo
I'm eating I'm just gonna keep eating
no no no no
good thing there's a chain ah the sewer
chains we all know of them oh
man good thing even in the future they
remembered to have everything
with big dangly pits have chains on them
go towards the light
towards the light
wow oh turns out it's more poop
all right
now it's over I'm free
God safety feels so good why does it
smell so bad though
ah classy
[Laughter]
it makes me laugh
all right
y
okay
well that was fun shoot the 10 tacos
all right if you say so
thank you
all right there's got to be a lot of
goodies around here and the interesting
glow things not sure what it is but it's
the future
as many interesting glowy things as
possible actually I will have to say
this game does have a succinct lower
amount of uh random glowy [__] than
other games that are said in the future
which I appreciate there's a diversity
of design here
now what happens if I get up on the
other side here
thank you oh thank you
if I had to describe the movement in
this game it's perfect it's it's
purposefully clunky
you're clunky and it's not exactly fast
or Nimble oh that's fine
hey whoa what the hell why were you able
to get a hit on me
five whoa whoa whoa
three
oh God that one okay you do three that
way no you're not doing three
that's what you get and you are mutating
don't do it again
oh hey
I don't like you threes you better not
three me
I'm looking for it
oh it was there
that's what you get
where else are you doing that's how you
do it uh sure the poop won't get in the
way that needle going into my neck
you know usually they do alcohol swabs
too sanitize the area of injection but
uh
that's for babies
that's not for me big strong man you
gonna do three
hey whoa hey whoa
I'm trying to shoot the Tentacles please
no thank you thank you thank you no
thank you thank you no thank you thank
you no thank you all right
well that was nice
certainly my arduous Adventure is over
and I get the safety of secure
safenessness
[Music]
what is down there what is in here which
way was the way I was supposed to go and
which way is not
hi
what is that
Health gel huh
cool I mean it is basically just Health
goop so I do appreciate that
storage it's definitely
you
so storage is definitely the extra stuff
I'm guessing probably
gotta be what is what in the what where
what okay
and this is a magical lifty thing yeah
I love the future
I love it
oh
I just get a bad feeling that I'm going
the wrong way even though I know I'm
probably not going the wrong way and
this is probably definitely the right
way right
isn't this the right way to go I mean
not the right final way but side pathway
I don't know there was that dark
stairwell maybe the dark stairwell was
there was supposed to go this seems
final
oh no I'm goofing it I goofed it
oh I definitely goofed it I've this is
the continuing path definitely for sure
for sure for sure I'm never coming back
God damn it I missed it oh well whatever
I'm stressed about nothing it's fine no
one out there is mad at me it's all good
right guys right no one's mad at me
no one's mad at me
huh oh God I hate that
all right
man this sounds real cheerful down here
I don't remember why I needed to do all
of this instead of taking the nice
comfortable tram system
that was really cool
how that was an option for literally
everybody else and then because the
other person locked me in the cell I
have to go the same way
which is super cool
wee oh boy what what
happening
there was a lot of goopiness and I
didn't know what was going on
oh great
that's not good
all right good
uh do I want oh no no not yet not yet
not yet not yet not yet there's a thing
there's a thing go back go back go back
oh just just a lot more
careless behemoth
I don't know if that was actually going
to attack me or what I'm going in I'm
going in there's no distinct direction
of where is the right way to go so I'm
just gonna go the first way that I go
and if it just so happens to be a bonus
area that's that and I won't bemoan not
getting any bonuses
the gratuitous amount of flossing far
too much slosh
now would this stuff smell work
[Music]
you two for a good reason measure I
missed that was just a warning the first
one
again with the moaning sorry man that
was disorienting I apologize oh was this
a bonus area
was it was it just a bonus area
I have no idea
man I would love
I love that
uh-huh
wow
that was just a bonus area
fascinating so storage does mean
bonus
fascinating
all right
Who's down here does anybody down there
is anything down here wait what no way
no way no way what
what's going on
what
am I crazy was it a side area inside of
what I thought was a side area but it
was actually not the side area it was
actually the real area I think there
might have been another way to go I
guess if I went left when I dropped down
into the orange goo
I'm so confused I'm in the poop tunnel
again
and I'm gonna go left
and this is where I was supposed to go
oh I don't know why the return was so
far away
this is back wait
wait
then what's the
where am I going
where where am I go I don't have a map I
don't have a map
I have no method to my mappedness
no Maps
I'm so lost
I swear it dumped me out here
am I missing something
because it's not down here
there's nothing down here
oh oh you there was a butt oh there was
a button on it
ah it was right there all along
that is something that's nice
that's real nice look at that
wow
wow pretty cool
very cool my poop covered self doesn't
belong here
seems like the oxygen might be a little
funny
seems like something might be going a
little wrong with that
light we made it through a copy
about it
okay I got eyes in the tram station I'll
meet you there
feeling you weren't telling me
everything
well I mean
you know how it is what is this lights
is this lights no it's Bridge
because everything should be
disconnected here for some reason don't
know why
I don't trust that I don't trust that I
don't trust that I don't trust that
oh oh oh oh wait wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute wait whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa hey whoa hey whoa hey whoa hey
whoa whoa
whoa
hey bro can you do something about like
all of this can you do something about
literally all of the horribleness that
is occurring
like that like the grumbly do you hear
the grumbly I hear the grumbly
oh my God
why can't I run why can't I run running
would be so good right now running
running run there we go yes you're good
man
there we go well I'm not gonna worry
about that
yep not running anymore again
where'd he go
whoa
must
scared
oh
okie dokie
so I see a lot of things that say oxygen
processing but I'm not a
not entirely sure which ones you want oh
this that building right of course the
building
I don't care we gotta get that's locked
on down
[Music]
yo oh man
I'm assuming that they
they were talking it's like
psychopathically because they couldn't
have been talking out loud gesticulating
that much those would be impossible
okay man I thought I would add more
money than I did I was sure killing a
lot of things that were giving me money
but apparently not enough
maybe because I died the few times maybe
take some money away it would only be
fair I'm kind of curious about all the
Korean there's a lot of Korean I'm I
mean I'm appreciative of it but I'm kind
of curious as to why
the future
predominantly English 50 50 Korean
very interesting you have 600.
I don't want to make the stink gun uh
skunk gun I don't want to make it it's
fine it's fine
I guess I should upgrade the gun I just
haven't done that
so I might as well I like the oh
interesting
I don't know if I'm gonna start holding
my pistol like that but um
sure that Magazine's magazine I want
boom bullets I'll eventually one boom
bullets but I need more money
I don't have enough money
can I get some money
Spike wall
what am I looking at well I'm vaulting
ah ah no you don't
there you go
whoa
who's there
I'm out of the darkness thank you well
not who I thought I had
don't do that don't do that any of you
don't do any of you that
don't do that well I'm out of gerp but
it recharges apparently
man this is some foggy fog
yeah see I'm not really holding that
thing at the end so it's just kind of
dangling off like a goober I'm not sure
that helps my gun
just like dead weight in the front
escapes the grip down keeps the front
end from going all offy stuff hello are
you coming at me quick
what just one one oh pitiful
oh little baby oh no what wait please
I'm trying to stomp you
there we go oh a group back
oh I could have I could have baseballed
him into yesteryear
thank you
why did I need to do all this with the
oxygen seems really arbitrary that
everything would have fallen to pieces
and also all the lockdown systems would
prevent people from you know keeping
people alive on the station
whoa you dead why is it so dark why is
it so dark why is it so dark
fascinating
foggy
oh
oh oh do I have an extra no I don't why
would I
well the violins definitely aren't a
good sign
s they're trying to subvert my
expectations and they are actually a
good sign
there's class in the way
pretty drippy in here
la dee da
la la la
what am I doing
can I just smash this
I can just smash it
turns out I can
wow I would have been smashing things a
long time ago if I knew I could just
snap smash everything
oh boy oh boy
oh boy oh boy that's why I couldn't run
foreign
why are they so swampy and also was the
only reason to come in here so I could
leave
is that literally the only reason I'm in
here
okay whatever
I did something
I accomplished what I came here for and
no one can say otherwise
uh
uh yeah
yep
well
what's going on
uh-huh
did I come from there or
okay I did why did I go in that room
I don't know I guess it made the fog go
away and maybe I wasn't able to see this
probably
oh yeah that's good oh this is good oh
this is good oh yeah
oh good great
oh yeah
make sure to get it in my eyes whatever
I'm wallowing through
yep and
this place looks weirdly clean
mind if I borrow your neck for a bit
thanks pal you understand man Eliza's
gonna be like why were you still doing
that why why would you have done that so
much like I don't know you just told me
I could so I just never stopped doing it
just wanted to stab people
again and again again once you start
stabbing you really just can't stop
stabbing you just keep going
I think there was probably a health
thing that I didn't get there but
whatever that's fine
wow
all right
I'm gonna do this and then it's probably
Gonna Save and then I'm gonna I'm
lifting the lockdown
[Music]
the problem is I can't reach it the
walkway collapsed
hmm
well what is it going to take out the
train if it gets too bad well either way
that's all the time I got for this I'm
gonna definitely make sure it actually
saves
saving
okay it's saved definitely saved so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye-bye
[Music]